Hey youtubers it's Charlie since a lot of
you were asking for a longer Q&A because of
the finale I made this 20 questions, so it's
twice as long.
I saw a ton of good ones, so I tried to pick
questions that at least touched on everything
everyone was asking about.
Quick shout out to the giveaway winners, Congrats
to Maiti Shook, The Infinite Draw and Serena
Uri you guys all win amazon giftcards.
I'll be messaging you on your channels for
details.
I'm still going to be doing game of thrones
every week and giveaways, but the giveaway
will probably move to my legend of korra videos
on fridays or saturdays.
Now let's answer some finale questions.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet.
But here we go.
Question 1 - Savage asks could you comment
on Jojen's Death being a huge change from
the books?
Question 2 - LadyZelda asks Will we ever see
Rickon again?
He's with Osha possibly on Skagos up near
eastwatch by the sea
Question 3 - SaxOps aks I thought the Mountain
straight up died in the book after being poisoned?
Question 4 - Jessica asks Do you know what
the Bloodraven meant when he said Bran would
fly?
Question 5 - Decaposaurus asks do you believe
in the Robert Strong theory?
Question 6 - Valoran K asks what were the
skeletons rising from the ground?
Question 7 - Doctor Who 50 and Beyond asks
is this the last we see of the Hound?
Question 8 - Andrea asks Where do you think
Varys and Tyrion are going?
Question 9 - Uh Okayy asks Do you think Arya
Will Meet Jaqen H'ghar in Braavos?
Question 10 - fragkill asks Wasn't Lady Stoneheart
going to be in the finale?
Wasn't there a teaser poster?
Question 11 - Nikkenji asks Did we see Jojen
Warg in his final moments before he blew up?
Question 12 - Smangie asks which characters
do you think they will cut out of the story
next season?
Question 13 - Brian asks why did they change
Tyrion's Character?
Question 14 - Flaw Normandy asks will they
ever regain control over Drogon?
Question 15 - Siempre Viva says I know people
don't like Bran's story as much, but if they
ever made a Children of the Forest Spinoff
I'd donate my wigs to charity.
Question 16 - Jennie asks Do you think Melisandre
will give us more info on Jon Snow's true
identity?
Question 17 - Dylan asks Which Character do
you think has changed the most this season?
Question 18 - Krakitoko Games asks what's
Bran supposed to do now that he's with the
Three Eyed Raven?
Question 19 - Tribus HD asks what do you think
the best death of the season was?
Question 20 Shaya asks - How did Stannis move
an army that big to the Wall without running
into the Boltons?
and a Bonus Shae question - Jamie (no avatar)
asks Do you think she was a spy planted by
Tywin this whole time?
So thank you so much for submitting questions
you guys, I always like to do these time delayed
skype sessions.
Let me know if you want me to keep doing Q&A
videos for game of thrones every week.
Once I start doing more Legend of Korra and
Doctor Who videos it will be a little harder
so worst case scenario, I just start answering
questions inside regular bonus videos and
I just don't do separate Q&A videos so no
worries.
A lot of
you have asked and yes I'm still going to
be doing game of thrones videos every Sunday.
If you totally just found me be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
And to all of you who subscribed a long time
ago here's a couple of shows I want you guys
to get ready for this summer.
Teen Wolf Season 4 is premiering Monday next
week.
A lot of
you have asked me to do weekly videos for
that so I will.
There's going to be 12 episodes total.
Then later in the summer Legend Of Korra Book
3 is coming.
I know a bunch of you quit the show during
book 2 just because you didn't like it.
Book 3 is going to be amazing, so start watching
it again.
It's a nickelodeon show for those who don't
know.
But you can find it on itunes.
It probably won't premiere till July but I'll
keep you guys updated.
Then Doctor Who Series 8 and Outlander are
coming in August, you guys all know about
Doctor Who but Outlander is another big series
based on a bunch of books.
I haven't read them yet, but I will be and
I'll at least do a video for the premiere.
So you have all of the summer to get ready
for those two shows.
I only do videos for stuff I think is going
to
be awesome so you should check all those things
out.
But if you have questions about them just
ask me in the comments.
My next Game of Thrones bonus video will be
on Thursday or Friday, it will probably be
my top 10 moments from
season 4.
Right now click here to catch up on my season
5 predictions and click here for my finale
video.
Thanks for watching, this is going to
be an awesome summer.
So everybody give each other a high five.
See you tonight!